as you guys know i've been making a lot
of in-depth videos about apple silicon
based on a lot of info found within
apple's own
wwdc 2020 developer tutorial videos
and based on everything i've seen i'm
very confident that apple silicon max
are going to be much better
than a lot of people are expecting while
also having a much smoother transition
compared to when apple switched from
powerpc to intel in 2005.
now before i get into why i'm almost 100
certain that this year's apple silicon
max will not be more expensive
than current intel max i want to give
you guys three reasons
why this transition is going to be much
smoother than the last one
number one is that apple has been slowly
phasing out software
that won't run on apple silicon max like
them dropping support for 32-bit ios
apps in ios 11
dropping 32-bit app support in mac os
catalina
and requiring hardware to support
apple's metal api
which is why nvidia graphics cards are
no longer supported
these steps are very important because
apple silicon mac chips
cannot run 32-bit apps and because apple
gpus
use metal exclusively these changes lead
to the second reason why this transition
will be much smoother than before apple
silicon max will have
instant access to iphone and ipad apps
on
day one so even if mac apps aren't
perfect at launch
early adopters can instead rely on
natively running ios apps
to get the job done in fact developers
are already using swift ui
to create new apps that run natively
across apple's platforms
due to the main code being shared
between them
and finally reason number three is that
unlike the original rosetta
which emulated apps for intel max in
2005
rosetta 2 is much improved and it works
in a totally different way
instead of emulating apps in real time
which can greatly slow down performance
rosetta 2 can translate and convert the
app
during the actual installation
effectively creating an arm optimized
version of the app
before you've opened it and not only
that but it can emulate
old plugins and drivers as well so
unmodified intel-based apps
should actually run decently well using
rosetta 2
and don't just take my word for it some
developers who have access to apple's
developer transition kit
are already praising rosetta 2. longhorn
tweeted that he thinks the first gen
apple silicon machines
will be faster at running x86 code
than actual x86 cpus which is of course
referring to rosetta 2 and a senior
software engineer at disney animation
was stunned by how well rosetta 2 works
having absolutely no problem
even with complex code and performing
shockingly well
while doing it now you might be asking
if this year's apple silicon max are
going to be so
impressive why am i so sure that the
price will not go up well
first off we've actually been seeing
many leaks of the price going down
so we might get a 799 macbook
and a 1099 macbook pro
giving us a two hundred dollar price cut
from the current intel versions
and besides that we haven't seen any
leaks or rumors
pointing to the max actually getting
more expensive but disregarding the
rumors completely let's actually use
some interesting facts
and common sense to prove that apple
silicon max
will not be getting more expensive the
number one reason
is the fact that since apple is going to
be using their own chips
they only have to pay their own
production cost
instead of the price that intel charges
for their processors
which is obviously much more expensive
let me quickly show you guys just how
cheap apple silicon chips
have been in the past ihs market did a
teardown of the iphone 10s
and found that the a12 chip actually
cost apple
only 30 and they did the same for the
iphone 11 pro
and the chip actually cost apple 64.
quite a bit more but still pretty cheap
considering that it's the fastest
smartphone processor in the world
now unfortunately their teardown of the
11 ipad pro
with the a12z chip was for paid
subscribers only
so i couldn't access that but according
to analysts from trend force
the production cost of apple silicon mac
chips built on tsmc's
new five nanometer process should be
under a hundred dollars
compared to the 10 nanometer intel core
i3 chips
which are priced around 200 to 300
dollars on the market
analyst minshakuo also predicted that
apple switch
from intel to rmax would cut cpu
component costs
by 40 to 60 so based on this
we know for sure that using apple's own
chips
is gonna save apple a good amount of
money now apple basically has
two different options or choices that
they can make
in terms of the price let's start with
the first scenario
apple keeps the price of their max
unchanged from the intel models
pocketing the cash from the extra
savings thanks to using their own chips
and for scenario number two they
actually lower the price
of their max and keep their profit
margins fairly similar
to how they were before i personally
believe that this second option makes a
lot more sense
from a marketing standpoint and let me
explain why
one thing for sure is that there are a
lot of doubters out there
saying that this will be a very rough
transition and saying that it could be
years
before these new macs match up to the
performance and user experience of
current intel max
and a lot of those thoughts are based on
the previous power pc to intel
transition
and the fact that apple silicon uses an
entirely different
arm-based architecture so apple is in a
pretty tough position
because they want to make sure that they
don't lose their mac user base
to windows computers the safest bet is
to actually
lower the price because doing so would
gather a ton of attention
from the press because lowering the
price is the opposite of what apple is
known to do
and then if these maps are truly great
while also lowering the price they could
finally start eating up a lot more of
the computer market
and on the other hand if these first
apple silicon max don't perform
that well then a lower price means lower
expectations and a smaller chance of
people getting upset
if it doesn't work that well on day one
this is the complete opposite of what
happened with microsoft's
surface pro x which had very high
expectations
due to very high pricing causing users
to get pretty upset
with the lack of performance another
reason it makes more sense to drop the
price is because apple knows
that we're going through a pandemic
right now which is leading to higher
unemployment rates
and a drop in consumer spending that's
why raising mac
prices right now would be a very bad
idea
and that's exactly what happened with
the 1400
galaxy s20 ultra smartphone which had
very disappointing sales
so if apple drops the price of their
apple silicon max
more consumers will be able to afford
them especially during these times
and that's why apple's inexpensive
iphone se for
only 399 dollars has been a huge success
leading to a 32 percent year-over-year
increase of sales
in china even during this pandemic and
finally
the last reason for a price reduction
may actually be the most
important according to counterpoint
research apple can generate a customer
lifetime value
of 2400 over a period of 30 months
from a power iphone user just in apple
services alone
so apple's ultimate goal for the 399
iphone sc might actually be to get more
iphones in the hands of consumers
so that they can eventually spend money
on their services
and in-app purchases and since apple
silicon macs
are now going to be able to run native
iphone and ipad apps
they'll be even more tightly integrated
into the apple ecosystem
which means more sales of their services
and app store purchases
and since dropping the price of these
new macs will likely increase the amount
of max sales
there will be even more users
potentially getting into the apple
ecosystem
and spending the cash that they saved on
their mac on services
anyway so based on all of that it makes
absolutely no sense
for apple to raise the price of their
apple silicon based max
compared to the current intel-based max
and there's a good chance that the price
will actually go down potentially down
to a 200
price cut like some rumors are pointing
to if this video answered your question
go ahead and tap the like button
and click the circle above to subscribe
and definitely check out our new apple
product merch
right below this video thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
[Music]
one